(Durchsage) Dieser Zug
bringt Sie zu den Gates E.
Danke, dass Sie
über den Flughafen Zürich reisen.
Are you from Israel?
- Yes. Are you flying to Tel Aviv?
Yes, we are going to Jerusalem.
- Oh, very nice.
Ich heisse Jonas. Ich bin 26
und arbeite als Sachbearbeiter
beim Eidg. Hochschulinstitut
für Berufsbildung.
Seit meinem sechsten Lebensjahr
sehe ich nichts mehr.
Weil ich früher einmal gesehen habe,
erinnere ich mich gut an Farben.
Ich heisse Yves, bin 31
und komme aus dem Kanton Fribourg.
Von Beruf bin ich Radiomacher.
Schon seit meiner Geburt
sehe ich 2 %.
Wir haben dem Fernsehen
die Sendung vorgeschlagen,
weil wir v.a.
dank zwei Dingen reisen können:
dank der Technik und den Begegnun-
gen - Menschen, die uns helfen.
Und das
wollten wir unbedingt zeigen.
Can we come with you to Jerusalem?
- Yes.
Thank you very much.
Wir werden auf unseren Reisen
oft damit konfrontiert,
warum wir als Blinde
oder Sehbehinderte überhaupt reisen.
Die Leute denken,
wir hätten nichts davon.
Dabei können wir
die Stadt auch erleben.
Über Gerüche,
über Leute, die wir kennenlernen.
Das möchten wir unbedingt
weitergeben und zeigen,
dass Reisen
auch als Sehbehinderter Spass macht.
Dank den anderen Sinnen und den
Begegnungen habe ich oft das Gefühl,
dass wir beim Reisen
beinahe mehr sehen als Sehende.
Is that 100?
- Yes.
Thank you.
- You're welcome.
Is it near to go to the hotel?
- It's here.
Oh!
* Er lacht.
Da hat es einen Pflock am Boden.
Is it here? - Yes.
- Thank you very much.
Hello.
- Hi.
Müssen wir rechts oder links gehen,
um in die Altstadt zu kommen?
Nach links
und dann die Strasse rauf.
Thank you very much.
- Thank you very much.
Bye.
Hier ist eine Tür, nicht?
- Ja, hier ist eine Tür.
Thank you!
Du hast gut gemerkt,
dass das eine Tür ist. Ich staune.
Und jetzt, wo wollen wir hin?
Links, oder?
Sollen wir einfach mal losgehen?
Aber viele Sachen ...
- So Inseln.
Mit Bäumen.
Ja, ich glaube, es hat hier Bäume.
Ah ja, es hat Bäume.
- Tatsächlich hat es Bäume hier.
Praktisch, wenn man einen Hut trägt.
- Ja.
* Glasscheppern *
Huiuiui.
- Hoppla.
Solche Pfosten mögen sie auch,
an denen man sich
die Beine anschlagen kann.
Ah, du meinst, die stehen da, damit
man sich die Beine anschlägt?
Ja, ich glaube, die wurden
extra für uns organisiert.
Da müssen wir hier wohl
auch über die Strasse,
weil wir weiter geradeaus gehen,
nicht?
Ähm ...
Wir gehen nach Jerusalem,
weil wir herausfinden wollen,
wie das in der Stadt so ist,
in der die verschiedenen Religionen
zu Hause sind
und aus der
v.a. über Konflikte berichtet wird.
Wir wollen sehen,
wie gut die Leute da zusammenleben.
Einfach weitergehen.
- Geradeaus?
Ja, aber ich bin auch nicht sicher.
- Wollen wir es probieren?
Hello. - Ja.
- Sorry?
Braucht ihr Hilfe?
Wir gehen in die Altstadt.
Ist das hier oben?
Altstadt?
- Is that correct here?
Nein, nein. Da lang.
- Okay, this way.
Wartet - die Strasse!
- Ja.
Er sagt, wir sollen gleich hier
gegen links über die Strasse.
Wartet! Jetzt könnt ihr gehen.
Now?
Hier hat es
so eine Art Fussgängerstreifen.
Ist er noch hier?
- Ja.
Also wer er? Er oder es?
And now straight on?
Er ist weg.
- Ah, er ist weg.
Oh nein, jetzt konnten wir uns
nicht mal mehr bedanken.
Ich bin sehr gespannt,
wie die Leute mit uns umgehen
und ob auch etwas
von den verschiedenen Religionen
im Umgang mit uns zu spüren ist.
Abgesehen davon bin ich gespannt
auf die bedeutenden Wahrzeichen
wie die Klagemauer, den Tempelberg
oder die Grabeskirche.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Das ist es doch wahrscheinlich.
Wollen wir jemanden fragen,
ob das hier ist? - Sorry.
Sorry.
Jetzt sind wir wahrscheinlich drin.
Jetzt sind wir wohl in der Altstadt.
Sorry, ist da das Jaffator?
- Genau.
Willkommen in Palästina.
- Nice to meet you.
Thank you.
- Das hier war einmal Palästina.
Ah, und jetzt sind wir
im christlichen Viertel?
Jetzt ist es
israelisch-palästinensisch.
Wollen wir noch wegen der SIM-Karte
fragen? - Ah, ja.
Wo können wir eine SIM-Karte kaufen?
- Fürs Handy?
Ja.
- Kommt, ich helfe euch.
Can I ... Sorry, can I ...
- Yes?
Can I hold you like that?
Ist hier das christliche Viertel?
Links ist das christliche Viertel
und rechts das armenische.
Für uns ist es wichtig,
dass wir überall Internet haben,
weil wir häufig mit dem Handy
navigieren und Dinge nachschlagen.
SIM card?
- SIM card, yes.
Eine israelische SIM-Karte
wollt ihr? - Yes.
Für wie viele Tage?
- Acht.
Have a seat! Sit here!
Okay, du kannst ein bisschen sitzen.
Er muss euch
einen fairen Preis machen.
Hoffentlich.
Er haut euch nur
ein bisschen übers Ohr. * Lachen *
So, mein Freund,
kann ich dein Handy haben? - Yes.
Soll ich ihm mein Phone geben?
- Ja.
Ist schon gut, oder?
Es braucht schon Vertrauen.
Aber man hat es vielleicht gemerkt:
Man muss versuchen herauszufühlen,
ob es die Person gut meint
oder eher nicht.
Was ist das Passwort?
5, 7, 5, 3.
Seid ihr zufrieden mit ihm?
Ja, schon fast. We're happy soon.
Die Basis des Ganzen
ist unser Vertrauen in die Leute.
Wenn wir das nicht hätten,
würden wir schon gar nicht gehen.
Das ist wie die Bahnhofstrasse
von Jerusalem.
Ja.
Ui, sorry.
Yves?
- Jonas?
Jep.
- Hier bist du.
Hat dich jemand angerempelt?
- Ja.
Das hier ist wahrscheinlich
wie eine Markthalle.
* Lachen *
Nicht, dass sie uns noch nachkommen.
Schon ein bisschen mehr ...
- Über Dach.
Jetzt ist es wieder offen.
Der Boden hat geändert,
hast du es gemerkt? - Ja, stimmt.
Er ist viel glatter.
Ah, verkauft der hier etwas?
Verkaufen Sie hier etwas?
- Nein.
Geht es hier lang zur Klagemauer?
Nein, ihr müsst hier runter
und dann links.
Wenn ihr möchtet,
kann ich euch hinbringen?
Thank you. Okay. Can I hang on?
- Yes.
Thank you. That's great.
Nice to meet you, bye.
Wie heissen Sie?
- Jerome.
Sind Sie jüdisch?
- Nein.
Palästinensisch?
Armenisch?
- Nein.
Christlich?
- Ja. - Aha.
Thank you very much. Very kind.
Thank you.
* Rhythmische Trommelschläge *
Es hat viele Leute hier.
Ja. Das ist
schon mal ein gutes Zeichen, oder?
Ich glaube, wir müssen noch
durch die Sicherheitsdetektoren.
Man müsse sich angemessen anziehen.
Ja, deshalb trage ich lange Hosen.
Ja.
Es gibt verschiedene Eingänge,
nicht?
Ja, durch welchen
sind wir wohl gegangen?
* Hupen *
- Oh, Achtung!
Ich glaube,
wir gehen hier auf der Strasse.
Ah, ja, hier.
- Oh!
Yves?
- Ja?
Gehen wir hier lang?
Steht, wir sollen
weiter rechts gehen? - Nein.
* Schnelle Trommelschläge *
Oh, jetzt kommen wir hier
mitten ins Fest.
* Trommeln, Gesang *
Jonas?
Ah, hier.
Jetzt weiss ich nicht,
ob es geradeaus oder links geht.
Weisst du das?
- Nein.
Da vorne ist irgendetwas.
Etwas aus Holz.
- Ah, das ist ein Konstrukt.
Was ist das wohl?
- Ein Gerüst.
Ah, wird dahinter gebaut?
Hier, nicht?
Ich glaube, hier ist ein Eingang.
- Oder ist es ein Ausgang?
Soll ich mal fragen?
- Ja, komm.
Sorry.
- Ja?
Wollt ihr zur Klagemauer?
- Ja, genau.
Nimm meine Hand, mein Freund.
Nimm meine Hand!
Sind Sie auch ein Besucher?
Or are you working here?
Nein, ich bin Tourguide.
Dürfen wir
mit dem Hut zur Klagemauer?
Ja, man braucht einfach etwas im ...
nicht im, aber auf dem Kopf.
Not inside your head, on your head.
- Okay.
Ihr könnt aber auch
eine Kippa haben, wenn ihr wollt.
One kippa for you.
Okay, my friend. Okay.
And one kippa for you.
- Thank you.
Den Hut könnt ihr auf die Kippa tun.
Okay?
Okay.
Aha, like that?
- Yes.
Take my hand and go with me please.
Jetzt hast du ihn einfach
darüber gezogen? - Ja, so.
Aber ich verstehe nicht ganz,
warum wir die Kippa ...
Aber das hat sicher einen Grund.
- Das ist fürs Gefühl.
Es war gut,
dass wir eine Kippa bekommen haben,
so konnte ich mal spüren,
wie die überhaupt aussieht.
Ich dachte immer,
es sei ein etwas grösseres Hütchen.
Und nicht, dass es nur so einen
kleinen Teil des Kopfs bedeckt.
Das ist die Klagemauer.
- Ah, okay, thank you.
Fragt sonst einfach um Hilfe,
das ist kein Problem hier, okay?
Thank you very much.
- Schönen Tag.
Thank you. - Bye.
- Bye.
Das ging jetzt schnell bis hier.
- Ja.
Beten die hier wohl oder reden sie?
Hör zu!
* Sprechgesang *
Bei uns ist es an religiösen Orten
doch immer so ruhig.
Ich weiss eben nicht, ob man die
Leute hier stören darf oder nicht.
Wenn die hier am Beten sind.
Der spricht zwar ...
Sorry.
Darf ich Sie etwas fragen?
Ist dieser Teil hier nur für Männer?
- Ja.
Sind Sie aus Jerusalem?
Ich lebe in Israel, aber
ursprünglich komme ich aus Paris.
Sprecht ihr Französisch?
- Ja.
Wunderbar!
- Oui.
Jeden Montag und Donnerstag
nehmen wir die Thora heraus,
wie alle Juden.
Und so hat es heute
auch viele Bar-Mizwas.
* Fröhlicher Gesang *
* Geistlicher Gesang *
Bar-Mizwa ist wie die Erstkommunion
bei den Katholiken.
Mit 13 Jahren
wird hier der Junge zum Mann.
Vorher trägt der Vater die Verant-
wortung für die Taten seines Sohnes.
Ab 13 Jahren trägt der Sohn
selbst die Verantwortung.
Ah, voila.
Alles, alles Gute.
- Bonne journee, merci.
Bonne journee a vous.
- Merci. Tout de bon.
Bonjour a la Suisse.
- Oui, on dit, on dit.
* Geistlicher Gesang *
Die Mauer ist sehr glatt.
- Uneben. - Ja, sehr.
Ou, jetzt ist ein Zettel
rausgefallen. - Oh, nein!
Willst du auch einen reinstecken?
- Hast du einen Zettel?
Ja. Warte kurz!
Wir haben gehört,
dass ganz viele Leute
Zettel in die Mauerritzen stecken.
Im Vorfeld fragte ich mich schon,
wie diese Ritzen wohl sind.
Ich konnte mir das
nicht so recht vorstellen.
Deshalb haben wir ein Papier
und einen Stift mitgenommen
und haben vor Ort auch einen Zettel
mit unseren Wünschen geschrieben.
Wie viele Wünsche
darf man wohl aufschreiben?
So viele wie du hast.
Hast du so viele Wünsche?
Aber ist das nicht ... Soll man sich
nicht mit einem zufriedengeben?
Oh, das gibt ein Kunstwerk.
Das Praktische ist,
dass es niemand lesen können muss.
Doch, Gott,
aber der versteht das schon.
Es hat fast keinen Platz mehr
für Wünsche. - Ja.
Diejenigen, die runterfallen,
sammeln sie scheinbar
im Frühling und im Herbst auf.
Dann kommen sie auf den Ölberg,
auf den jüdischen Friedhof.
Die Wünsche sind sicher
via Mauer in den Himmel.
Daran glaube ich schon sehr stark.
Da geschieht schon etwas.
Ich glaube schon daran,
dass es eine Art höhere Macht gibt.
Darum hoffe ich natürlich,
dass die Wünsche in Erfüllung gehen.
Wollen wir mal rausgehen?
- Ja.
Ist es nicht mehr rechts?
Willst du mehr nach rechts gehen?
- Ja.
Warum?
- Hier ist alles vollgestellt.
Kommt, ich helfe euch.
Hello. Warte! Thank you.
Thank you very much.
- Bye.
Wir müssen doch noch
die Kippa zurückgeben?
Wo ist sie?
- Auf unserem Kopf.
Ja, klar. Ihr könnt sie mir geben.
* Fröhliche orientalische Musik *
Die Destination ist ... oh ...
Mount of Olives.
Ich bestelle eins, okay?
- Geht es?
Order now.
* Klingelton *
Oh, jetzt hat er wohl eins.
Yakir kommt uns abholen.
* Unverständliche
Handysprachausgabe *
Er ist noch 400 m von uns entfernt.
Dann ist er schon bald hier.
Viele Handys
haben ja eine Sprachausgabe drauf,
die einem alles vorliest,
was auf dem Bildschirm steht.
Das macht es möglich, dass wir ein
"normales" Handy bedienen können.
Mit der Zeit
haben wir die Sprachausgabe
immer schneller eingestellt.
Wir verstehen sie so,
weil wir die Sprachausgaben
schon extrem lang nutzen.
Noch 1 Min., noch 0,1 km,
also noch 100 m.
Hier? Ah, nein.
Jetzt hat es geklingelt,
d.h., es ist hier. Ah, hier.
Are you a taxi?
Oder jener dort drüben?
- Ah, jetzt ruft er an.
Komm, Yves.
Hallo? Sehen Sie uns? Wir sind eben
blind, wir sehen Sie nicht.
Könnten Sie vielleicht hupen?
Bye, bye, okay.
Was macht er?
Sorry. Er ist weg.
Er geht wieder?
- Ja.
So ein Arsch.
Also, ich bestelle ein anderes.
Ah, jetzt ist er hier.
* Hupen *
Ah, hier.
Hello?
Lass uns nachfragen.
Klopf mal ans Auto!
Sind Sie ein Taxi? - Nein,
aber 10 m weiter vorne wartet eins.
Ah, weiter vorne?
- Ja. Okay.
Sind Sie ein Taxi?
- Ja.
Sorry, wir haben Sie nicht gesehen.
- Kein Problem, ich habe gewartet.
Very nice.
- Thank you very much.
* Fröhliche israelische Musik *
Sind wir jetzt schon auf dem Ölberg?
- Ja.
Thank you.
- Thank you. Bye.
You're welcome.
- Bye.
Schön.
- Super.
Hier sind wir jetzt.
- Ja.
Ich wollte v.a. auf den Ölberg,
um zu versuchen,
die Aussicht etwas zu spüren
und zu fühlen,
was man von dort genau sieht.
Ich wollte auch
ein bisschen das Klima spüren.
Hui, das windet extrem.
Huiuiui.
Woher kommt wohl dieser Wind?
Krass.
Es windet extrem.
Hello? Sorry.
- Braucht ihr Hilfe?
Ja. Könnten Sie uns vielleicht etwas
beschreiben, was man hier so sieht?
Oh, sehr viel.
* Yves lacht. *
Es ist sozusagen die gesamte Sicht
auf die Altstadt von Jerusalem.
Im Zentrum ist der Felsendom.
Er ist blau, und seine Kuppel
ist aus Gold. - Ah, okay.
It's blue and the dome is golden.
Ah, okay.
Wir sind auf der Seite
des jüdischen Friedhofes.
Auf der anderen Seite des Tales,
unterhalb der Stadtmauer,
befindet sich
der muslimische Friedhof.
Ah, okay, yes.
Also, weiterhin gute Reise. - Merci.
Und danke für die Beschreibung.
Merci beaucoup,
c'etait cool de te rencontrer.
Merci beaucoup.
- Amusez-vous!
Toi aussi! Bonne soiree. Merci.
Ciao, ciao.
Es gibt doch so einen Panoramamodus.
Da fährt man so hin und her und
dann gibt es ein schönes Panorama -
wenn man es kann.
- Aha.
Und jetzt fühlst du dich überlegen,
weil du diesen Panoramamodus hast?
Nein.
Nein, es bringt mir ja nichts, denn
ich habe ja kein Instagram wie du.
Ja, ja, du kannst schon lachen.
Kann ich dir helfen?
Ja, ja. Wir können ja
noch ein Selfie machen.
Das können wir ja besser.
Du schaust schief.
- Ah.
Jetzt. Zwei Gesichter.
- Ja. Jetzt musst du aber ...
Uh, ja.
- Warte schnell!
* Unverständliche
Handysprachausgabe *
Jetzt. Drück!
Nochmals!
- Nochmals? - Ja.
Spürst du jetzt Jesus hier?
Wieso? War er hier?
Ja, von hier aus
ist er doch in den Himmel. - Ja?
* Schnelle orientalische Musik *
Ich liebe Wasser über alles
und finde Baden super.
Im Meer allgemein.
Von Leuten, die schon im Toten Meer
waren, hört man ja,
dass das Baden dort
ein einmaliges Erlebnis sein soll.
Das Gefühl,
auf dem Wasser liegen zu können.
Dieses Gefühl reizte mich.
Can I go inside?
Um ans Tote Meer zu fahren,
haben wir ein Taxi genommen,
weil es hier in Jerusalem
nicht so einfach ist mit
den öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln.
Wir hatten uns ein bisschen
informiert und herausgefunden,
dass es
mit dem Taxi am einfachsten ist.
Wie lange geht es bis ans Tote Meer?
Eigentlich 40 Min.,
aber manchmal hat es Stau.
Und von dort ist es nicht mehr weit
bis nach Jordanien, oder?
Nein, man kann die Häuser sehen
auf der jordanischen Seite
des Toten Meeres. - Okay.
Könnten Sie uns etwas beschreiben,
was man unterwegs so sieht?
Wir fahren nun Richtung Jericho.
Das ist eine Strasse für alle.
Die Palästinenser können sie
benutzen, aber auch die Israeli,
weil sie in die Westbank geht, aber
auch zu jüdischen Siedlungen führt.
Rechts könnt ihr die Mauer sehen
zwischen Israel und Palästina.
Das ist also die Grenze ...
... between the palestinian
and the israelian side.
Ah, okay.
Und müssen wir nicht
durch einen Checkpoint?
Nein,
weil wir in diese Richtung fahren.
Ah, okay, it's only to ...
Schaut mal, auf der anderen Seite
hat es sehr viele Autos.
Haben die Palästinenser
einen anderen Pass?
Sie haben
einen palästinensischen Pass.
Ich gehöre zu den Arabern,
die in Jerusalem leben.
Wir haben entweder einen jorda-
nischen Pass und eine Israel-ID,
oder einige haben
die israelische Staatsbürgerschaft.
Wie ist es denn für Sie,
in Jerusalem zu leben?
Es ist sehr schön und speziell.
Ein Segen!
Ich bin hier geboren,
und unser Haus gehört meiner Familie
seit der jordanischen Zeit.
Wir werden
unsere Häuser nicht verlassen.
Aber ist es manchmal nicht auch
schwierig? - Sehr schwierig. Sehr.
Aber was können wir machen?
But what can we do?
Wir müssen geduldig sein.
Ich habe viele israelische Freunde,
weil ich
in einem Hotel gearbeitet habe.
Es gibt auf beiden Seiten
gute Menschen und schlechte.
Auf beiden Seiten.
Vielleicht sind ja
gar nicht die Menschen das Problem.
Nein,
nur die Politik ist das Problem.
Der Politik sind die Menschen egal.
Sie kümmert sich um anderes.
Es geht ums Geschäft.
* Nachdenkliche arabische Klänge *
Ich habe es sehr interessant
gefunden, was Mahmud gesagt hat
und wie er dieses Leben akzeptiert.
Vielleicht hat er sich aber auch
einfach eine gute Art zurechtgelegt,
wie er das erzählen möchte. Ich habe
mich noch nicht entschieden.
Ich merke einfach,
dass es eine ganz andere Welt ist.
Und diese Welt zu verstehen,
finde ich schwierig.
* Orientalische Klänge *
It's hot.
Das ist ja heiss
wie in einem Backofen.
It's hotter than in Jerusalem.
Es ist 10 °C heisser
als in Jerusalem.
Warum denn das? Nur weil es
auf einer anderen Höhe liegt?
Ja, wir sind hier
400 m unter dem Meeresspiegel.
Hier vorne
reiten Kinder auf einem Kamel.
Wow, es gibt hier Kamele!
Ah, es hat Kamele hier.
So gut.
Come here.
Here is a chair.
- Ah, thank you.
Es sind einfach Stühle.
Wollen wir gleich ins Wasser?
- Ich glaube schon.
It is not far to the water
from here.
Können Sie uns zeigen,
wo das Wasser ist?
Thank you.
Können wir dann einfach
immer weiter ins Meer hineingehen
oder dürfen wir
nur ein paar Schritte machen?
Ihr könnt schon etwas reinlaufen.
Da vorne ist das Wasser.
This is my friend.
Hello.
Er ist ein Freund von mir,
er wird euch helfen.
Thank you.
- Die Schuhe könnt ihr hier lassen.
Okay, come.
Wie ist es?
- Es ist herrlich. - Grossartig.
Ihr werdet nachher jünger aussehen.
Geniesst es! Ich bin hier,
wenn ihr raus wollt.
Thank you very much.
- You're welcome.
Das ist ja unglaublich.
Ich bin hier.
Es ist ein Supergefühl,
da drin zu liegen
und es einfach geniessen zu können.
Man schwebt eigentlich
über dem Wasser.
Ich glaube, dieses Gefühl
werde ich nie mehr vergessen.
Es ist unglaublich.
Yves?
- Ja?
Liegst du?
- Ja, und du?
Ja.
Zweimal Hummus, bitte.
Jetzt geht es gleich los.
Oh, Fladenbrot.
Hier ist der Hummus.
Das Pitabrot.
- Ja.
Und hier Falafel.
Oh, wow, thank you.
Thank you.
Hat jeder einen eigenen Teller?
Du hast hier Falafel.
- Ja.
Ich verstehe es nicht ganz.
Wo ist denn der Hummus?
Ah, hier. Nein, das ist Salat.
Das hier ist Hummus.
Auf dem Teller?
- Ja.
Brot hast du schon, oder?
Die Falafeln sind hier vorne.
Das ist sehr lecker, ja.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Mmh.
Shukran!
Und jetzt weiss ich nicht,
ob hier ...
Ah, hier ist eine Bank.
Wollen wir uns hier hinsetzen?
Ja, hier ist eine Bank.
- Ja.
Hm, es riecht etwas streng.
- Wirklich?
Wonach?
- Hm. Nach Kacke.
Wirklich?
- Du sitzt auf Kacke.
Ah, nein.
Ich rieche es nicht.
Wir gingen in Jerusalem
zum Fussballclub Katamon,
weil wir im Vorfeld gehört hatten,
dass dort Menschen verschiedener
Religionen zusammen Fussball spielen
und so einander näher rücken.
Wir haben dann
im Internet recherchiert
und schnell dessen Website gefunden.
Und so kamen wir zu Uri Sheratzky.
Hello, I'm Uri.
- Hello, nice to meet you. I'm Yves.
Yves and?
- Jonas. Nice to meet you.
Jonas, nice to meet you.
Ich habe euch
ein kleines Geschenk mitgebracht.
Eine Mütze von unserem Club,
Schutz vor der israelischen Sonne.
Thank you.
- Thank you very much.
So you can put it
on your head afterwards.
Also, ich erzähle euch mal etwas
über den Katamon-Club, okay?
Jerusalem tut nur so,
als ob es  e i n e  Stadt wäre.
Aber das täuscht -
es sind drei Städte.
Eine für Menschen wie mich:
nicht-orthodoxe.
Eine weitere Stadt
ist die der muslimischen
und der christlichen Araber.
Und die dritte Stadt
ist die der orthodoxen Juden.
Jeder Teil hat eigene Schulen.
Einige haben sogar ihren eigenen ÖV.
Some of them have even
public transportation on their own.
Alle haben eigene Nachbarn,
eine eigene Kultur
und eine eigene Sprache.
Es sind also drei Städte.
Also heisst das, dass jeder Teil
seinen eigenen Fussballclub hat?
Nein, da kommen wir ins Spiel.
Wir versuchen, ein Ort zu sein,
an dem sich die drei Kulturen
der Stadt treffen können.
Es ist sehr kompliziert.
Aber wir haben Fussballfelder
in der ganzen Stadt und Schulen,
mit denen wir arbeiten.
Von den israelischen Siedlungen
bis zu den arabischen Stadtteilen
ganz im Osten.
Uri war ein ganz cooler Typ.
Er war sehr unkompliziert, offen,
er kam schnell zum Punkt,
also zum Club.
Man merkte, dass das
wirklich seine Leidenschaft ist.
Er lebt für das.
Und man merkte auch,
dass er auch mit uns
keine Berührungsängste hatte.
Ich fand es schön,
das so von ihm zu spüren.
Darf ich mich halten?
- Yes, sure.
Was habt ihr denn
schon alles gesehen?
Sehen ist vielleicht
nicht das richtige Wort.
Nein, nein, das ist schon gut.
Wir waren an der Klagemauer
und am Toten Meer
waren wir dann auch noch.
* Ein Mann
gibt Anweisungen auf Hebräisch *
Ist hier das Fussballfeld?
- Ja.
In front of you
is a football field. - Ah, yes.
Now you can touch it.
- Ja.
Da hat es noch Sand drin.
There's sand in it.
Spürt ihr,
wie heiss der Kunstrasen ist?
Es ist schwierig, darauf zu spielen.
This is Digati.
Nice to meet you.
- My name ist Digati.
Sie sind der Trainer?
- Ja, vom Jugendsektor.
Dann hat es hier also
Palästinenser, Muslime und Christen?
Palästinenser ... nun ja.
Aber es hat Araber, Äthiopier.
Jede Kultur ist vertreten.
From all the cultures.
Okay.
Palästinenser
könnten bei uns beitreten.
Aber wenn die Palästinenser
einem jüdischen Club wie unserem
beitreten, bekommen sie Probleme mit
ihren Leuten in ihren Stadtteilen.
Deshalb nehmen sie nur an den inof-
fiziellen Aktivitäten von uns teil.
Man darf auch nicht
in der israelischen Liga spielen,
wenn man keine Israel-ID hat.
Wollt ihr mit einem arabischen Vater
sprechen? - Yes.
Abuhalled!
Hi, I'm Jonas. Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
Hello. Welche Sprache sprichst du?
- Englisch.
Ah, nice.
- Und was sonst?
Arabisch, Hebräisch und Französisch.
- Ah, okay.
Und ich bin neun Jahre alt.
- Wow.
Und wer ist der beste Fussballer?
Ronaldo und Messi.
- Ah.
Spielen Sie auch Fussball?
Ich habe mal gespielt, aber jetzt
bin ich 46 und ich bin Anwalt.
Der Alltag ist schwierig hier
mit all den Problemen.
Probleme - was meinen Sie damit?
Wir können nicht ignorieren,
dass die Situation hier
nicht einfach ist.
Es gibt viele Konflikte.
Aber wenn die Menschen
in sich drin einen Spirit finden,
um zusammenzuleben,
dann können sie zusammenleben.
Wenn wir die Politik beiseitelassen,
dann können die Menschen
es gut haben miteinander.
Und das schönste Beispiel dafür
ist dieser Fussballclub.
* Orientalische Klänge *
* Fröhliche Musik *
So wie ich es erlebt habe,
hatte ich den Eindruck,
dass die Leute alle
ziemlich tolerant sind.
Das ist eigentlich noch schön
und passt nicht so zum Bild,
das ich vorher von Jerusalem
und Israel gehabt hatte.
Spannend finde ich, dass man es
ja meistens den Kleidern ansieht,
wenn jemand sehr religiös ist.
Das sehen die Sehenden ja sofort,
auf den ersten Blick.
Vielleicht sehen sie
auch sonst den Kleidern an,
ob jemand Jude oder Muslim ist -
oder sogar,
ob jemand Polizist ist oder nicht.
Und das sehen wir nicht.
Das finde ich eigentlich noch schön.
Ich finde, das ist
einer unserer grossen Vorteile,
dass wir nicht urteilen, bevor wir
mit jemandem gesprochen haben.
Dadurch nehmen wir die Stadt
ganz anders wahr.
Weil wir den Leuten eben
nicht ansehen, was sie sind.
Weil wir eben nicht sehen,
was so rumläuft.
Sondern wir entdecken
einfach einmal die Stadt.
Und die Leute,
mit denen wir ins Gespräch kommen,
lernen wir kennen.
Das jüdische Viertel
und hier das armenische.
Jetzt versteht ihr,
wie die Altstadt funktioniert.
Und wir sind hier?
- Exactly.
Die Zeit hier in Jerusalem
war wirklich grandios.
Es war sehr schön.
Und was wirklich über allem steht,
sind die Leute.
Uns wurde immer geholfen
und v.a. sehr unkompliziert.
Einfach auch
die Selbstverständlichkeit,
dass man uns etwas zeigt
und mit uns mitkommt,
das ist grossartig.
Das kenne ich sonst
von nicht so vielen Orten.